hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
lyophilization changing the game for
molecular diagnostics
my name is michelle ashton and i'll be
your moderator for today's events
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by thermo fisher
scientific to learn more
visit thermofisher.com let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
and any time you want during the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker jerome
caboo
senior business development manager
licensing and commercial supply
at thermo fisher scientific to learn
more about our speaker
please visit the speaker tab at the top
of your screen
jerome you may begin your presentation
welcome
so ladies and gentlemen welcome uh we
are here today
to talk about the life realization and
how we can change the game for molecular
diagnostic
my name is jerome kabu i'm working for
demo official scientific as a senior
business development manager
licensing and commercial supply
the agenda of the discussion today is
going to be first an introduction to
lyophilization
then some consideration about the enzyme
selection
and the process development of the
lyophilization
and finally how we can help as a company
let's start with the introduction to the
lyophilization
to to in short to to explain what is
lyophilization it is a process
of freeze drying a product
so the product is in solution it's going
to be
totally frozen then placed into
a vacuum and the ice is going to be
removed
through the sublimation sublimation is
the main
piece of the process of lyophilization
this is going to allow you to have
of course a product more stable at room
temperature
but also is going to keep
all the different characteristics of
your biological material
intact in the process
here you can see the different faces of
a product you have the solid of course
liquid and gas
sublimation as i said is the main piece
in the freeze drying process
and this is when a solid
go into a gas phase without
passing through the liquid step
you have to consider a two interesting
point here the triple point
uh this is as a pressure and temperature
where
a molecule can be in solid liquid and
gas phase
and also the critical point this
critical point is when your product
has a maximum temperature after what is
going to start to melt or
collapse this is going to be quite
important
in the other step for the lyophilization
if we go back in time lyophilization
is not that new in fact
south american people in the ants try
to preserve potatoes in 1250
before christ then it was
really developed by a french guy arsene
darson val at the beginning of the 90th
century
he was trying in fact to remove water at
low temperature
for distillation so it was really
when we discovered the lyophilization
process
then during world war ii we used this
process
uh to have stable product like
blood plasma and penicillin of course it
was really important
during the second war um a little bit
later
we use it to a lyophilized coffee
and also to life lies
food for apollo mission and also for our
military
more recently in the 90s lyophilization
was used in the pharmaceutical and
biotechnology market
for drug and vaccine development
nowadays
it is used in many different molecular
essays
and of course it's really interesting
because of the speed and accuracy needed
by
molecular diagnostic essays
the new platform for molecular
diagnostic on the market
are very often now easy to use and fully
automated
to have something like sample to answers
tools you can use it for different
diseases like infectious disease any
kind of genetic
testing prenatal oncology and and
many other use
the main benefits of the lyophilization
is first of all the ease of use
when you have a lifelike product you are
going to reduce
the chance of preparating errors and you
don't need
fully trained people to do the test
of course it's going to eliminate uh
some costs
like a cold chain shipping and it can
help to reduce globally the cost of your
solution
then it will allow you to have a stable
product
at room temperature and very often
extend
the life of your product that could be
of course really interesting then
last point is the sensitivity of your
essay
as you are going to have more room for
your sample
you can detect and have a test that is
going to be more sensitive
than the classical web format
but of course in doing this
lyophilization
you can have different kind of
challenges
the main one of course is to start with
exception selection and formulation we
will go back
on this later in the presentation but of
course
selecting those are really really
important
second point is also the choose of your
enzymes
you have to understand that not all the
enzymes are the same
and choosing the best one is going to be
a
very important point to do the
lyophilization
you don't want to have glycerol into
your enzymes so it's it's going to be
very very
important in your decision
then the design of your primers is going
to be also
very very important because as you can
understand when you are doing the
lyophilization steps
uh it can change the way your primers
are going to
to work on
other consideration um if you would like
to
develop your process in-house
you may have to invest massively in into
lyophilizators
and it can be quite quite costly and
also
everything related to process
development
is going to be very important
now let's continue with some
consideration
about the enzyme selection
a very important thing to know is that
your essay
is only as good as your enzyme
this means that not all the enzymes are
the same
and you need to consider a very high
performing enzymes to have a better
essay so looking at the sensitivity
processibility the inhibitor tolerance
thermostability all those
characteristics are very very
good to to check before creating your
essay
having some enzymes with low dna
contamination
is also very important because it could
interfere
with your results of course
to to now available on the market you
can find
some layer ready enzymes that are here
to help you
in your molecular assay development
having a
already enzyme means that you will have
a very low content
in glycerol in your enzyme
but for us it's not only going down in
glycerol it's also doing some
optimization
and be sure that your enzyme is going to
have the same sensitivity processivity
and all the characteristics they have
when they're in presence of glycerol
to do so we we have to do of course some
optimization
and our solution available our optimized
enzyme
so the different enzymes available now
you have to check three main point if
you like to have
an ivd kit that is going to be
c marked or validated by svfda
so the three main pieces of that are
going to look at the performance
of the enzyme and again it's looking at
inhibitor tolerance thermostability
processivity specificity
and low residual dna contamination
then it's going to look at the
consistency uh
having specific qc tests to be sure that
you have consistent results with your
enzymes
and finally the quality
used to to make your enzyme you will
need some
level of certification to have those
included
in your final essay
we have a long list of layer ready
enzymes
available today i'm not going into
details into that but
we have different reverse transcriptase
available
some isothermal enzymes also
then tuck dna polymerase and dna
polymerase with proofreading activities
here we would like to show some results
of different tests using a couple of
enzyme
one enzyme is a superscript rt
as a reverse transcriptase and the
second one is the platinum two
attack dna polymerase so we created a
one step
rtq pcr mix with those two enzymes
and we tested into a duplex
detection of par influenza and
coronavirus as you can see
here um we have very often better
results
in terms of amplification efficiency
but also insensitivity uh
in doing different kind of dilution for
those tests
performing the same kind of test with
human mrna
is going to provide the same kind of
results we have the best amplification
and also the best sensitivity in
comparison to
other available products
with coronavirus there is a
big need for a very fast
testing and this created a big
call for new solution like
loop mediated isothermal amplification
or lamp
pressure here you can find that we
developed some solution and we have
available now
some dna polymerase for lamp but also
ert enzymes and many different enzymes
other products sorry like
cyber green or cyto16 for
the colorimetric readout of a
lamp detection
if you don't want to develop yourself a
solution using different enzymes
you can also go directly for master
mixes
lie already we developed internally two
different
tuckman layer ready master mixes uh one
to work on dna on the left here
and one to a one-step solution to work
on rna
the two products are working on
multiplex they are compatible with fast
cycling
they are using a specific amplitude
that is fast activating and
they are provided in a 5x format
we have different options for those
products with or without
rocks and also different pack size
if you need specification and also
customization
of this solution
doing some tests uh with tacman layer
ready one step uh qpsr master mix
we compare it with one of our best
sellers the tacman fast virus
and we did that in simplex on the left
and also in triplex on the right here
you can see that we obtain
at least the same results and sometimes
even better results
uh using the layer ready version of the
product in comparison to the classical
pacman phos virus
then doing some testing again
in comparing the lye already one step at
acupuncture master mix and the tuckman
fast virus
you can see here that on
different kind of targets we obtain the
same
the same kind of results and the two
master mixes are
working in the same way
now let's go for some consideration
around the process development
of the layer featurization
so the first stage when you are doing uh
your lyophilization uh it's going to be
the freezing uh so
this this freezing step is going to be
of course
really important and you may have to
optimize this
and you are going to create a solid
phase
of your product
then secondly you are going to create a
specific vacuum
and then you are going to increase
the temperature uh and you are going to
do this very slowly
of course to create this sublimation
we discussed in the first part of this
presentation
doing so you will do what we call the
primary drying
and you will have left only five or ten
percent
of water into your your essay
then you will go for a secondary drying
where you are going really to do the
disruption and
eliminate any strong water bonds
into your material and you will finish
with only one or two percent of water
in in your essay
here i will show you a video
it is a freeze dry microscopy video
that is going to show the transition of
a lyophilas product from liquid to
frozen
then finally to dry state
at the end of this video you can see
that
your essay is going to collapse
this is all you are going to determine
in fact your collapse temperature
when you are doing for real your
lyophilization process
of course you don't want to reach this
collapse temperature
and stay beyond that
now to do the lyophilization you will
need different kind of components
one component and the first one that we
are going to see
is the excipient excipients are
here to stabilize your biomolecule and
also add bulk
to your lyophilized product so
those one are really important you have
in fact
two different kind of exceptions
you have the cryoprotectants
and then the layer protectants
the cryo protectants are here to
stabilize
your structure in fact and protect your
biological material
the leo protectant are here to to
protect your material
from the dehydration
we are not going to see into details all
the different
uh possible category here
but you have to know that sugars
are very often used and are very
effective because they can act as creole
and leo protectants
other really important piece in your
essay are going to be
the buffers the bulking agents and the
surfactant
the buffers as all the buffers are here
to prevent any big ph change into
your product so you can
choose different buffers here and
it's recommended to use low
concentration of
different kind of buffers to find
the best one the bulking
agent here you are going to add that
of course to support the structure
of your biomolecule
typically here you can use different
kind of
disaccharides and it's going as
we said to help you have the
correct shape and structure of your
bio-molecule
finally the surfactants are going to
reduce
the absorption and aggregation of your
biomolecule
and we have some examples here
very classical products
now regarding the infrastructure you
will need
to do that to do the lyophilization
you may consider in buying a different
kind of lyophilizer
you can go for a small scale product
or instrument and this will allow you to
do maybe 100
vials or plate at a time
they are small they are consuming
some energy of course but it's there is
nothing to do with
the large-scale lyophilizer
in those big ones you can do thousands
of
vials of plate in one cycle
but of course they are really really
more expensive and they are using
a lot much more energy
so it's it's really important uh when if
you consider to to do the lyopidization
yourself
uh to be sure that you have correct
infrastructure
and you are ready to pay for very
expensive
instrument to do so
when you have your lyophilized product
it's going to be very important to to
check the humidity humidity is going to
be
your enemy here so
to do that you you will have to think
about package
you are going to use maybe
have this silica gel desiccant
to have a correct level of humidity
but also if you have a single use
product
using a vacuuming product as a package
it can be a good solution
if you would like to use your product
multiple times and have a long term
storage
of course you will have to check the
temperature but clearly control the
humidity
and you can do that with specific dry
boxes
every step in fact of the
lyophilized essay journey past the
lyophilization
must be really carefully looked and be
sure that
you you will have the best product and
solution to
to to check humidity
all along the way
so if you go for uh some general
utilization consideration um
as mentioned earlier you can think about
building
your own facility of course
this will give you all the control
of the supply chain but of course you
will need to have
a certain amount of of a certain volume
of manufacturing
so it makes sense for your company to to
build that
another option is to outsource to a
third parties or layoffulization you can
find
on the market different kind of cdmo's
that are expect
experts in light optimization and
they can help you in doing this process
but of course it's going to add
a step in your supply chain
and add a specific bender to that
finally you can also partner with your
region inventor
just like us we can now
there is supply lyophilized product
that you feel like it says directly
in 96 well plate are cheap tubes
and of course it's much more convenient
because you only have
one vendor to do all the different steps
here
no matter what you are going to choose
we are here and we are
happy to help you
and this is the last part of my
presentation
how we can help you
if you consider the path from concept
to market for a specific essay
you can have the four main pillars that
are
rnd of course verification and
validation
then the manufacturing and finally the
commercial launch
we can offer all along this path a
different solution it can be enzymes it
can be
instruments sample preparation solution
different kind of controls we have all
of this available
in our portfolio but specifically if you
look at the rnd
and verification steps
we can do customization and optimization
of our solution for you so you have the
the appropriate product in your end
if we look at the manufacturing and
commercial launch
here we can add some specific services
like a fill and finish
heating and packaging lyophilization
as we saw and also specific private
label
if you have to look at the different
steps to convert
a wet essay into a lyophilized format
there are three different steps the
first one is of course to test
your essay with liar ready enzymes
this will allow you to confirm that your
essay is working
with liar ready enzymes or master mixes
and maybe you will have to optimize a
little bit vsa
at this stage
next step it's going to do a pilot scale
manufacturing so here you are going to
confirm
that your lyophilized essay is
performing
as expected and it will allow you to
lock down
the formulation all the different
specifications
and determine the correct test and qc
testing
of your essay finally
the last step is going to be the
analytical validation
here you are going to do a real
production scale
manufacturing and you can confirm with
these steps that
everything is working as you like
and be sure that the test
is as good as you expected to go on the
market
finally i would like to mention again
that
we can now provide some liophilization
services
meaning that we can take different kind
of fly already reagent
adding specific exceptions we developed
internally and add primers and probes
to do single or multiplex essays
and do the lyophilization
you will then receive directly strips
tubes or plates
as you want with your essay ready to be
sold
on the market
and this will end my presentation
i'm happy now to take some questions
thank you jerome for your informative
presentation we will now start the q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for all right let's go ahead
and get started
your first question is i have developed
an infectious disease
qpcr assay and want to move this assay
to lyophilized format
how much optimization is needed to swap
out my hot start tac polymerase with
your lyo ready
enzymes
okay so this is a great question
but i don't have an easy answer um so
it's
it's really going to depend on on which
hot start tag polymerase you already
have
if you are using as an example the
thermoficial scientific got started
dna polymerase like platinum tack
then we already have a liar ready format
and and this will not require a lot of
optimization
to do this transition in your essay
however if you are using a
non-thermoficial
scientific obstacle race
then switching will require some
optimization
[Music]
i would start of course this
optimization with the classical protocol
we can give you with our layer ready
enzymes and then trying to modify it a
little bit
to have better performance
okay your next question is i currently
have an
assay in liquid format how exactly could
you help to transition this to a
lyophilized format
so we can help you in in different ways
but the first thing to do
is of course to find the the layer ready
enzymes or different kind of regions
that can be used we to to
um to change from your actual liquid
format
uh so you can do some testing uh
in again in a wet format with those
light ready
enzymes or regions and if you need
if you have good results then it's it's
over
you can try to do the lyophilization and
see the results if you see that you need
to adjust a little bit
we can go and discuss with our r d
and we can help you to troubleshoot and
optimize
your essay to observe better results
thank you jerome okay and we have time
for one more question
this user says thank you for your
presentation i am starting to develop
a lyophilized master mix
do you recommend that i start with your
lyo ready reagents for the assay
or conventional enzymes from your
catalog then switch to lyo-ready
reagents
okay if you are if you are planning to
develop
a lyophilized essay there is no
need and i don't think it's interesting
to to develop it
with classical enzymes containing
glycerol
i would really recommend to start the
development of your master mix with
layer ready regent do all the
optimization
of the essay in a wet format
and then continue and do the
lyophilization
and all of our layer redirections
comes with a protocol and it's going to
help you to start in this process
and we have as you saw a wide
range of enzymes available so
if you would like to test some of them
let us know and we are happy to send you
some samples for
an evaluation
thank you jerome do you have any final
comments for our audience before we go
today
well i just would like to thank you uh
thanks everybody and just let everybody
know that we are more than happy
to work and help you in your life
realization process
and thank you again for your time today
and your important research
we would also like to thank flabbers and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
and labbers will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event
until next time goodbye